歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是阿倫
現在市場上最想要問的東西就是
打完美
有機會
哪個事情打完美
腳啊
除了打腳之外
我覺得比較意外的是
美伊又在講何談
重點是股市還吃這一套
油價還回落
沒錯
就是這件事情
竟然可以TACO了這麼久之後
大家繼續買蛋
你覺得原因是什麼
我觉得原因是大家可能现在就是需要一个利多
大家情绪比较低迷一点点
突然有一个小利多出来
大家就会放大去轰抬股价
是 因为前几天的成交量也比较低
今天也稍微放大
有到8000亿的量
而且今天上涨的加速可以说是百花齐放
反而前几天这个街榜演出的传产金融
今天是压力比较大一点
凌晨我们要等回答了
这次会不会打破魔咒
感觉开始在反应
我觉得还可以吧
好 因为我们昨天
有特别聊到一件事
挥打每一次法说
都超乎市场预期
但是股价都是跌
这一次遇到了油价跌
股价开始恢复上涨了
能不能上演大逆转
我觉得这一次
看起来是蛮有机会的
所以我乐观看待
要赌吗
不用赌
我们看晚上睡醒就知道了
那我们先看这件事情
就是一方面
伊朗跟阿曼這邊
也有做了一些動作
他們要去臨時航線給它開出來
要排水雷
不過商船是可以通行的
軍艦不行
另外一個美國
有把水域內的水雷都大致清除了
然後外交官準備返回
以色列、沙國、黎巴嫩跟伊拉克
就開始要做一些談判的動作
水雷可以再丟回去
然後他們也可以官員再送回來
對啊
所以到時候如果又發生
你講的這些事情嘛
是啊
這個就變紅色的啊
然後這個也變紅色的啊
我希望打完
打完我們的腳
就真的打完了吧
確實啦
但是目前看起來
好像也沒什麼
可以很明確的一個狀態啊
大家就是臨時又利多
臨時又利空的反應
對 所以我也只能說
我們就
對嘛 等一下來賓會講嘛
我們要有堅定的信心
但是我們要把眼光
可能就放到科技股的身上了
主场又回来了
没错
我们这个美债值一律
30年起的这个跌下来
可能科技股就开始走一个反弹
那也带动了今天的
其实昨天台值夜盘涨400点
早上开盘的时候
觉得奇怪怎么那么弱
被没收
怎么那么弱
可是盘中就发动了一个出量的攻击
所以我觉得非常不错
另外一个
这个就是Virabra Rubin
有一些相关的利多Groke要出来了
其實今天滿多VR Rubin相關的事情
就感覺他回答財報情好熱鬧
是的 所以我覺得這些
也有一些推升股價的狀態
像是他說吞吐量會是
這個GB300的30倍
資料的吞吐量
沒錯 另外一個Token的速度
推論速度會快4倍
所以我覺得也很不錯
那整個目前推論
會變成是一個主戰場
過去會是認為是
我要擴大基礎建設
我東西要越大越好
越多越慢
那現在呢 現在大家講效率
你可以不用大 但你要快
對對對
天下武功為快不破
是的 速度要快 延遲要夠低
成本期望可能能夠降低
那補齊呢 就是低延遲的這些推論的拼圖
就是Varubin計算家Golf的高速生成
就是他已經原本是
GIG這會 現在兩邊各專精這樣子
那就會變得比較有效率一點
再來成本下降就會激發需求去做增加
那另外呢 台廠的受惠時間就會相對去拉長
所以这些硬体厂
这个鸿海广达伟创
基本上就会是受惠的个股
那当然鸿海可能
大家现在认为
2027年会是最受惠的一个公司
那这个我觉得对长线
台湾的硬体厂商来讲
应该就会是利多
好 这个成本下降
真的还蛮重要的
因为现在零组件都在涨价
所以他一定要想办法
这边有一些东西
是可以让总体下来的效率
超过成本
是的
所以这个就看后面的状况了
那当然这个我觉得
对AI的发展来讲
应该会是利多
那当然还有另外一个利多
就是Anthropec
所以要充施IPO
原本有SpaceX
就是什么单
最大的IPO个股
地表最大IPO
对这个有可能要超过了
地表又来了一个更大IPO
所以大家现在钱其实真的很多
我们地表真的要产生很多东西
对啊最近呢
那个更新速度越来越快
那当然我们9月呢
也帮大家稍微整理一下
关键的大事
好因为8月最后一个礼拜
如果我们现在已经要准备
对不对发动那9月要接棒就要有很多事情是的 我們看到就是戴爾戴爾大家記憶有存就上一次公布財報的時候那個價格 大標對 然後也帶動台灣人家伺服器代工那一塊
就是比較中後段那一塊
也是標了一大波
另外還有像博通又要來了
然後半導體展
所以看有沒有機會
大家很重視
有沒有一些提前發酵的力多
那產品發表會很重要嗎
蘋果的產品發表會
其實好像滿重要的
我已經可以幫他下一個註解了
不了无心意
是的
就每一次媒体都这样说
对
然后再来就我们最重要的
台积电发源营收
对
然后制造设备站
日本的
是的
那另外还有美光财报
是
美光财报
好
OK
这个记忆体相关的
其实我觉得也蛮重要的
对
好
然后929还有OpenAI的开发者大会
对
这中间好像漏了一些东西
其实我刚好在看
因为没有联准会升息
对
但我想一想
因为科技是
科技業啦 對
所以應該也不會加進來
因為你在務的是聯準會
對 因為我記得
9月要升降息
但是不過沒關係
我們跟大家講的就是
這些相關的重點的一些數字
如果是好的
那我們剛好說到
現在8月其實有一些利多出境了
因為8月10號公布完營收了
然後8月也講完了法縮了
所以有點空窗期
那如果這些能夠帶來利多
我覺得股市表現
應該就會慢慢的
有再墊高的機會
好 當然兩件大事
一個是中秋節的廉價
這次可以連到四天
然後再來就是艾倫的生日
也在這個月
那她不好意思說
我來幫她說
放個一個月吧
好 我們看到大盤
沒有這種禮物
大盤的表現呢
我們昨天有說到
回測月線加前滴
然後打了第二隻腳 小腳
對 那這個區間呢
我們昨天有說
你要今天如果能夠做一個突破
那我覺得就是一個
非常強勢的表現
今天突破了
重點是量能呢
雖然還沒有到8500
但也有個8200
我覺得OK
就是上漲的時候呢
是有放量的
所以過關了嗎
我覺得給過耶
接下來要挑戰的就是這個地方嘛
這個前高嘛
那有兩個狀態
一個呢
當然最好的我們這邊先畫出來
然後這裡打
然後就做突破
突破就挑戰前高
這應該就沒問題了
可是有個狀況
我們就稍微注意一下
如果高點沒有過
那下來的話呢
就會注意要變成一個大區間震大
对所以目前大概就是两个状态
但今天这一根的整个表现
我觉得是非常不错的
就是你占卫全部均线
然后你突破小箱形
然后成交量放出来
所以多头是有进攻意愿的
对那如果这边呢
今天辉达稍微讲好听一点
然后接下来Jackson Ho
这个华许讲好听一点
那我觉得这很有机会
在近期内就去挑战这个
甚至是去做突破
辉达一定会讲好听的
市场买不买单啦
就是买不买单
所以真的不要來那個麻拆一下嗎
不用 好 我們要繼續跟他貴買
好啦 貴買也是一樣的道理
就是今天都是突破了這個箱形
守住月線突破箱形
那剛剛大盤要挑戰前高
那貴買要先挑戰季線
因為季線還沒站回來
再來呢季線站上才去挑戰這個
那如果行政應該自行
其實跟大盤一樣
我們就是挑戰前面的六月的高點
所以這邊大家可以再陸續看有沒有
有機會偏得更樂觀的狀態
我覺得已經偏樂觀了
有沒有更樂觀
就是前高要做突破
是
這個是大家要後續要觀察的
好 再來我們看到的呢
就是這個台積電
台積電今天又開地走高了
其實不錯啦
對對對
那也創下了這個
這一段時間以來的一個短線行高
但是一樣
我們就持續觀察
2450如果做突破
基本上我覺得大盤那個前高
應該就要做突破
好 我們有命命武器台積電
只要它往上攻
你說指數要創高
真的應該沒有太難
是的
對 所以我覺得台積電
今天也開始小放量
沒有到很大量
但是如果這邊做突破
量能持續去增溫
我覺得大盤就不用太擔心
蓄積能量 蓄積能量
沒錯 這邊就盤整
等待一個更好的狀態出現
那我們來看一下鴻海
因為剛剛提到Growth 3
它怎麼長成這樣
對 雖然它長成這樣
欸 怎麼了
沒有啊
它什麼時候你又走回去原點了
你不知道整個伺服器代工
這一陣子很弱嗎
因為我都一直在看
中小型還有像傳產航海王什麼的
對
這一票像是鴻海廣達偉創
然後還有像是
人保其實還算強
人保算強
它比較落後補漲
可是像音業達技嘉
其實前一陣子都有
下來一下下
對 那鴻海是
人家那個是上去很多下來一下
鴻海是上去也不多
下來也不多
就在這個區間震盪
但人家今天不錯
今天有站回五日均線
所以這邊在持續的主體中
也是一樣
今天成交量其實不太夠的
所以能夠先慢慢站回全部均線
然後慢慢量放出來
这个潜高才有机会去做突破
那才有机会形成一个大底部那目前是主体阶段所以鸿海我们刚刚提到嘛那基本面我觉得明年应该都持续没问题可是技术面上可能要有更好的转折讯号出现才是有动能出现啦
就只能当价值股
先放着了
对不对
没错没错没错
所以这个是目前
鸿海的形态
都还是比较温
温一点
温温的
所以可能要点耐心
好刚刚好
我们觉得
大盘现在的形态
确实走得蛮好看的哦
虽然艾文他不是很想
跟我去讨论
到底这一次回答能不能逆转胜
可是今天真的看到很多
回答相关的新闻
不晓得大家有没有留意到
里面有一条
其实讲到的是跟PCB的规格有关
所以下一段节目
我们就会来好好的聊一下
到底PCB现在占整个Vairroobin
或是下一代的Vairroobin Ultra
它的角色是什么呢
有什么样的东西
可以值得来做留意
当然如果大家需要
今天所有的图卡资料
记得订阅一下
赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
我們會免費放在首頁的貼文欄
那我們等一下就來拆解PCB的密碼
好 來
Grogrpx
我們到底要認識多少名詞
好累
對啊
Grogr是什麼東西
就是Grogr
Grogr
還要3
對
要國3次
對 國國國
國國國
好 OK 青蛙
好 全面浪產
台系材料其實是有受惠的
所以大家可以發現
其實今天的PCB上中油
表現是不錯的
當然板類也不錯
金像電 星星景碩
尾盤都滿強勢的
今天板類是有起色的
是的 所以我覺得還不錯
這整個規格的提升
會帶動了CCL跟HVLP4同波
還有PCB相關的材料升級
目前是採一個混搭的方案
M9搭配的是Q布
M8搭配的是Rodicade 2的
這個波纖布
有不同的組合
所以這個東西拆開
會變成這樣一層一層一層的東西
沒錯
所以這個就
大家又開始討論的就是
PCB感覺不管你是哪一個東西
它就是一定是基底
它那個基底一定要在
就是升級這件事情又來了
是的
所以整個的一個PCB的
上中有間的表現
其實是蠻強勢的
那包含了就是台光店
不過最強的是三哥啦
今天連貿是漲停的
第二根
因為連貿聽說是比較不受規格影響的
是喔
他跟著漲價就對了
而且他很便宜
股價啦
那目前來說呢
台光店已經取得M9材料認證
然後呢
並進行M10的認證
M10囉
是的
那京居呢
其實台灣就獨有這一家啦
所以他有他自己的獨有的地位
好 但是很多的觀眾朋友就說
他都是獨有了 獨家了
他的股價怎麼沒有獨家感
沒錯
這個大家的感覺我也懂
對啊奇怪
股價怎麼不太會動
不過呢
等一下還是幫大家解析一下技術面上
然後德宏就是Q步
不過呢德宏確實最近的股價也比較辛苦
對那富橋最近的股價就不太辛苦
最近股價要創歷史新高
今天盤中一度快漲停擺
好這個是相關的一些個股
那當然我們今天呢
也幫大家稍微再繼續
這個大方向的統整
好漂亮啊
對今天都紅通通的
當然今天行情不錯啦
那整个EPS呢也都红色的
至少看来对啊
自己是用红色的
没人赔钱
对没人赔钱
所以目前这几位啊
在今天啊都没有全部
但有一些个股
陆续的在今天的成交量
都是稍微放比较大一点点
所以我觉得它有开始要进攻的讯号
而且比较整齐
是比较整齐
然后个股的成交量
有稍微陆续的在做一个小放大
我们现在看到的就是台药
台光店呢
比较贵一点点
而且已经创历史新高过了
是的
那连帽呢
下不来
所以呢
我们就来看一下
卡在中间的二哥台药
不过台药可能就会有面临到
因为像连帽可能就把一些
中地市场吃走了
是的
对
台光店就是一定是最高阶
要干嘛
它都一定领先
但台药就要追
它就有点夹在中间
对
要上不上要下不下
但也可以啦
它也是陆续的
有在做一个M10的认证
那只不过
前一阵子这一波的行情
哇
他就一个人很憔悴啊
然后憔悴到破千
跌了一千块
那目前来说呢
这一波反弹行情
他这一波也很强
那这一波是大家一起反弹
可是呢
到现在还在反弹呢
只剩下连帽
那目前来说
今天你看这两天
成交量都开始在陆续的
有没有到爆大量
但有陆续的小出量
小出量过程中
来到月线的位置
那今天也破坏了下降趋势线
所以我觉得这个形态上
跟这个成交量上
大家短线上就可以开始
好好注意了
因为停车店很好抓
我就越线跟昨天的低点跌破
那我就出场了
可是呢如果这些再拉回全部均线其实今天差一点也有啦10亿均线差一点站上但如果这边我们能够反弹上来甚至能够过高拉一个N字形然后去挑战前高那我觉得这个赚培比
应该就值得去好好注意一下
突然这个图
它本来这样弯下去
觉得结果你画一个N字形
突然就漂亮起来了
因为这两天其实
像昨天其实我觉得
很漂亮的原因是
很多个股都拉下引线
然后有拉下引线之外
因为它是先杀后拉
所以有一些个股量能都有放出来
那就是等于底部放量的下引线
那今天行情又不错
所以有延续拉两根红K的
我觉得都可以稍微注意一下
是一个好的讯号
尤其像这种差一点站为全部均线的
接下来就是等一个过高
如果高点能够做突破
那我觉得这个行情就至少先挑战前高
再来看有没有机会创历史新高
再来看到下一位就是京剧了
他为什么可以长得又是横盘
因为说实话不管这个PCB
用在哪一代的Ryarrobin之類的
他銅箔都是一直聽到要他
對啊 股價就是
寡讚
重點是他這一波跌還很兇
600跌到破300
他前面是700多 抱歉
不好意思
700多跌到200多
接近300
跌到快3的數字
那這一波當然也有反彈
但是你可以發現
談到這個地方
很多個股創歷史新高的
反彈5、60%以上的
季线都站不稳
这条季线都站不稳
这个季线目前在接近500块
480几块的位置
所以它也要先挑战季线去创高
才有机会往更高的路走
那不过呢
今天一样
我们都帮它找这种
这个量蛮漂亮的
当然这里也有一次
那这里也有一次呢
我们要观察的是什么重点
是这个最大量的高点
要有一个收盘价的突破
这里曾经有一次想挑战
但失败了
失败
对那今天又想要来挑战
目前没过
那目前没过要注意
明天是不是又要下来
然后再继续做一个区间整理
所以大家这边可以留意的是什么
当我在这边做一个区间震荡
如果我是抱持有耐心的人
我的停顺点就是抓这个前低
有跌破的时候
那后面让它盘整
可是我比较追求有效率一点点
那也不怕买贵的朋友
那就是这个高点
确定有个收盘价站上
再来去做介入
因为这也是大箱型
如果能够突破
那这个行情后续
应该会有一段向上的延伸
所以目前来说
京均它在目前的
这个区间内
坐游走的时候
就是要嘛你就抱着等了
要嘛呢
你就动能出现在操作了
那今天有先出量
所以明天有机会
但能不能过
回到收盘价再来确定
对这个是大家可以去观察的
京均
好这个是在动能
对不对
今天的话
为什么体感温度会比较好
就是因为它的整体性比较强
然后就像你讲的
连续两天之后
那种动能感有跑出来了
对的
所以后续注意一下
然后再来看到最后就是尖点
赚针也是要嘛
而且是消耗品嘛
而且赚针也是PCB各厂说
一定要技术提升
规格提升的啊
单针啊
就那一根针会越来越贵
毛利率会越来越高
而且需求越来越大
确实股价曾经也是很飙过
对那目前来说
我们跟京区遇到一样的状况
就是在一个大区间内做震荡
横盘的整理
那这个整理呢
你可以发现今天也放量了
所以跟京区一样
如果明天延续性能够拉出来
而且能够守到尾盘
然后站上这个大量的位置
这个都是一个形态上的转折
所以我们刚刚我们昨天有去讲的是
光宝科形态上的转折
那今天确实继续垫高
对 所以间点也是一样
跟经驱观察方式是一样的
我在这边做横向整理
那我能够抓的停顺就是这低点跌破
那接下来能够发现动能
发生动能的就是这个大量的高点
要去做收盘价的站上
那届时应该就会有一段新的行情
可以做期待
所以目前来说
我帮大家看的就是今天PCB
然后量能有在放大的
那明天可以好好观察
有没有进一步让形态好转的现象出现
也许就有一段短线的动能可以去做把握
好 所以其实我们今天选的股票
有一个特色
就是因为PCB接下来遇到
不管是辉达或其他的大厂
他们在规格上面可能都会有一些调整
可是不管是专针或铜箔
他们其实是有所谓的寡占地位的
不容易被取代
所以他们现在在盘整
通常是给机会
以及刚刚讲到像台光店
它所有高阶的涨价的升级
它都有
台药也在往这个部分做努力
所以我们有搭配
所谓产业的知识
那这边艾伦说的QR Code
也欢迎扫一下
因为明天他要送你
比较特别的东西
他不是用全景图了
他今天帮大家
直接用技术形态来筛
就是有没有刚刚我们讲到的
低档转强动能
已经出现的PCB股票
大家可以锁股之后
练习一下看看他们之后
是不是也顺势沿着技术形态往上走
如果又具备产业地位的话
会更优质